I
it is in fact in the life of a people or
nation that the notion of self conscious
reasons actualization of the holding in
the independence of the other complete
unity with it or having from my object
the free thing hood of an other which
confronts me and is the negative of
myself as my own being for myself that
the notion has its complete reality
reason is present here as the fluid
universal substance as unchangeable
simple thing hood which yet burst
asunder into many completely independent
beings just as light versus under into
stars as countless self luminous points
which are their absolute being for self
are dissolved not merely implicitly in
the simple independent substance but
explicitly for themselves they are
conscious of being these separate
independent beings through the sacrifice
of their particularities and by having
this Universal substance as their soul
in essence just as this universal again
is their own doing as particular
individuals or is the work that they
have produced
in paragraph 350 Hagel is beginning a
long long process of clarifying for us
the relationship of the particular
individual that the self-consciousness
now understood is a moment of reason all
of us are as individuals reason and that
reason is also something exceeding us as
well the relation between that
individuality and this Universal
whatever it is the ethical life in this
case he's going to talk about the life
of a people or nation German word for
that that Miller is translating as
people or nation is Foulke and we don't
want to you know imagine too many of the
negative connotations that come up with
that because Hagel it doesn't have that
in mind we see it as we go through the
phenomenology what he means is any sort
of community any kind of community where
there's an identity you could say there
is a commonality there's something
bringing them together they possess some
more or less agreed upon and recognized
mores or customs or rules that is what
what at this point is comprising a folk
and nation and he says that it's in the
life of a people our nation that the
notion of self conscious reasons
actualization then he's going to tell us
what that means in a moment that it has
its complete reality so does that mean
that we can't have relations with other
people outside of our own particular
community no not at all as a matter of
fact part of the the main thrust of
Hegel's theory of history is that we
actually break out of the confines of
our own little communities into a more
universal consciousness and he thinks
that the enlightenment plated major role
in in that the western enlightenment but
you know if Hagel were around today
probably take into account
Enlightenment's happen
in other cultures and what's going on
present today with globalization now all
that said what are youse concentrating
on here is the relationship between the
individual and their particular folk and
he says what's going on there there the
the realization or the actualization of
self-conscious reason involves be
holding in the independence of the other
complete unity with it or in other words
having for my object the free thing hood
of an other which confronts me and is
the negative of myself as my own being
for self so something very dynamic is
happening here within the realm of
ethical life within a people it's not
just a matter of everybody knows their
place and nobody ever steps out of their
place no as a matter of fact what we
find out in post communities is that
people are constantly renegotiating
their their places that and that you
know what what happens in actuality
often doesn't conform to the ideal and
people talk about that and argue about
that and what's going on there you argue
with somebody else not just to put them
in their place to shut them up or push
them away but because you want some
recognition of the rightness of your
position at bottom you actually want to
exist in some sort of harmony it may not
be a complete or free harmony you know
but something like that what with the
medievals often called concord concordia
with other human beings now that's like
I said that's you know something to
happen later on that's an ideal that's
not always realized but it is something
that is animating what happens within
the life of as he's calling it a nation
or a people and now he says here's
another important transition reason is
present here as the fluid universal
substance where have we seen this talk
about fluid universal substance before
well think back to all the paragraph
we're hagel talked about life as a fluid
universal substance we're going to see
something similar to what happened with
life understood as a universal happening
now with respect to this universal
substance which is the self
consciousness of the people or nation or
what have you the community he says
reason is present here as this is
unchangeable simple thing hood but it
bursts asunder into many completely
independent being so that's what we're
representing here right now bersa
thunder it scatters itself and what is
the metaphor that Hagel uses here notice
what he says just as light burst asunder
into and what would you expect him to
say next as you're reading it if you
haven't read it before the natural
assumption particularly given Hagel's
time we're in the Natural Science they
were quite interested in making sense of
color and light well you know you set up
a prism and though the white light goes
into it and it bursts into the whole
rainbow right Hagel doesn't say that
what does hey you'll say instead the
metaphor is an astral one it has to do
with the stars with constellations very
interesting isn't it the fact that he
chose that metaphor instead so he says
light burst asunder into stars as
countless self-luminous points which in
their absolute being for self in how
they are for themselves are dissolved
not merely implicitly in the simple
independent substance of light but
explicitly for themselves we're the
stars for us as human beings make their
most sense I mean we've got astronomy as
a science we can study an individual
star it's in relation to other stars we
constellated a constellation of
something that's you know fixed for us
and our we go out we look at
Big Dipper those of you who are in the
southern hemisphere you're probably not
going to have the same reference points
as I'm using here for a northern
hemisphere audience and so I apologize
to you and really know much about the
constellations about the south I don't
even know enough about those of the
north so i'm going to use once you go
outside you look up at the sky see aha
there's the Big Dipper and over there's
the Little Dipper and I follow out the
dipper the dipper spoon and we can find
the North Star as you know cetera etc
etc and we take those for granted as
kind of calm fixed points they're not
really fixed points at all as we know in
a universe where everything is expanding
and where the light that's reaching us
is in many cases many centuries old we
are constellated them we produce their
meaning as associated with each other we
receive a lot of cues about how to do
that from the society that we live in
the constellations are looked at
differently in different cultures aren't
they so we can go on and now let's use
this metaphor to talk about self
consciousnesses right these self
consciousnesses are related to each
other within the framework of a living
developing society which is the
universal substance and he says these
individual beings are conscious of being
separate independent beings through the
sacrifice other particularities this is
why you can never like truly be a
completely independent individual you're
always doing so at the expense or really
living off of you might call it the
cultural capital of the society that has
given you so much do that there is no
such thing within the Galleon framework
as a self-made man or woman and we're
better off recognizing that to be the
case because so long as we remain caught
up in this ideology will never really
see things fully or even
more partially then we do already it was
me in a better partiality he says it's
through the sacrifice of our
particularity that we reconnect with
this universal substance he says by
having this universal substance as their
soul in essence now there's a there's
also a polarity going backwards it's not
just a giving of oneself to this is Oh
take my particularities I individuality
it's worth noting you have it it all
just be whatever you fill me up and want
me to be Oh wonderful society we're not
just re-enacting the unhappy
consciousness here Hagel goes on and he
says the individual the universal again
is their own doing as particular
individuals or is the work that they
have produced there's a dialectic here
there is a back and forth between the
society the community I'm using these
terms interchangeably I know that some
people like to make rigid distinctions
between them just go with what I'm
saying or the universal right and the
individuals and their relationships that
constitute them there's a dialectic
between them that has to be explored
further
the purely particular activity and
occupation of the individual refers to
the needs which he has as a natural
creature that is as a merely immediate
individuality that even these its
communist functions are not frustrated
but enjoy an actual existence is due to
the universal sustaining medium to the
might of the entire nation but in the
universal substance the individual has
this form of subsistence not only for
his activity as such but no less also
for the content of that activity what he
does is the skill and customary practice
of all this content insofar as it is
completely particularized is in its
actual existence confined within the
framework of the activity of all the
labor of the individual for his own
needs is just as much a satisfaction of
the needs of others as of his own and
the satisfaction of his own needs he
obtains only through the labor of others
as the individual in his individual work
already unconsciously performs a
universal work so again he also performs
the universal work as his conscious
object the whole becomes as a whole his
own work for which he sacrifices himself
and precisely and so doing receives back
from it his own self there is nothing
here which would not be reciprocal
nothing in relation to which the
independence of the individual would not
in the dissolution of its being for self
and the negation of itself give itself
it's positive significance of being for
itself this unity of being for another
making oneself a thing and a being for
self this universal substance speaks its
universal language and the customs and
laws of its nation but this existent
unchangeable essence is the expression
of the very individuality which seems
opposed to it the laws proclaim which
each individual is and does the
individual knows them not only as his
Universal objective thing hood but
equally knows himself in them or knows
them as particularized in his own
individuality and in each of his fellow
citizens in the universal spirit
therefore each has only the certainty of
himself of finding in the actual world
nothing but himself he
is as certain of the others as years of
himself I perceive in all of them the
fact that they know themselves to be
only these independent beings just as I
am I perceive in them the free unity
with others in such wise that just as
this unity exists through me it exists
through the others too I regard them as
myself and myself in them
what is Hagel doing here in paragraph
351 it looks like he's laying out a
particularly idealized and even you
might say dilek version of society and
its relation to the individual and
individuals which would easily make him
the target for pretty much anybody who's
getting more realistic viewpoint on
power relations and historical
development now of course Hagel is not
stupid and we should always assume that
so we want to think of what what is
really going on here is this something
that can just be turned into a stalking
horse for some Marxist or foucauldian
zor Nietzscheans or whoever else who
would like to say things are never as
harmonious as what we're talking about
here or if they are what you're talking
about Hagel is something like a
corporate fascist state and we don't
want that that sort of thing what has to
be the case well if we want to assume
that Hagel does understand that things
are never quite so simple as that but
didn't we have to that and say what is
happening is we're attempting to go to
this is sort of like you know when the
Marxist talked about you know what what
society would be like after the
Revolution after the proletariat takes
control of the means of production than
this this is more like it and this is
not supposed to be a working model for
exactly what's going on but what Hagel
is talking about here and of course this
is all so imperfect to is how
recognition how incorporation of persons
works within the framework of societies
where most people do in fact exist not
just now no but but his story so this is
a one paragraph let's follow out what
he's saying most of it is going to fit
into here in this nice diagram that I've
given to you but let's do a lot of
reconstruction alone wait he says the
purely particular activity and
occupation
individual refers to the needs which he
has as a natural creature that is as a
merely immediate individuality so we
think back to hunter-gatherers you need
to go out and get something that you can
eat and probably some other raw
materials that you can fashion into
tools shelter you know we have more
complex we have you know the guy who who
gets his government portion of land and
you know the plow animal and the plow
and some seed and there you go buddy go
homestead or something along those lines
we have we have all sorts of things that
we might imagine of this sort and many
individuals are in fact working
primarily as they think about it for the
purpose of their immediate satisfaction
of meats or that of not just that but
also their their family right the little
microcosm of society he says though that
even these it's countess functions are
not frustrated but enjoy an actual
existence is due to this Universal
sustaining medium to the might of the
entire nation again remember folk nation
could be a smaller community and here
might be useful for us to think in terms
of like hunter-gatherers right
hunter-gatherers we think of them as
these independent reliant individuals no
they think of themselves as belonging to
a man and what we're talking about here
the might the power the might of the
community is what permits the individual
to work for his or her own needs even if
we're talking about you know this 40
acres and a mule ideology which
unfortunately was not administered very
fairly all sorts of abuses that went on
what was able to happen happen because
the person was not entirely on his or
her own out there in the wilderness but
he had some other people working with
them and had something else besides just
a bunch of other people there was a
sense of community
work same thing we might say with
monastic communities going out into the
wilderness originally to you know spend
more time with God with that they had
grow their own crops and builder their
stuff and eventually they become the new
glee I for entire communities that that
turn into towns so Hagel is on to
something here there's always more going
on this almost sounds Marcia doesn't it
so it is more going on economically and
in terms of valued production than meets
the eye here's part of what's hidden in
this he goes on he says in the universal
substance the individual has this form
of subsistence not only for his activity
of such but no less also for the content
of that activity what he does is the
skill and customary practice alone so
what I'm doing for myself thinking about
it is just for myself is not just for
myself or what I'm doing within the
scope of my family what I think it is
just for my family isn't just for my
family if I inculcate for example in my
children a sense of self-reliance and
responsibility for their own actions and
you know honesty or even if I'm just
like the ancient Persians is Xenophon
tells us about you know I teach them to
ride a horse shoot the bow and speak the
truth right that doesn't just apply to
me or the little microcosm of my family
it has wider implications also being
defined a jerk and screw up and I mess
up my family I'm not just messing them
up for me that it's not going to read
out to myself it's also going to affect
the wider society as well from a
deadbeat dad for example don't don't
nurture my children knowledge them Hagel
doesn't talk about that he's talking
more about the positive here but that
would have an important implication so
he goes up and he says is content
insofar as it's completely particular
is is in its actual existence confined
within the framework of the activity of
all this massive economy that's going up
how does that work says the labor of the
individual for his own needs the
individual works to try to get something
out lay our might write the works and
he's supposed to be getting something
out of it but what happens he also ends
up satisfying the needs of others
without perhaps even intending to
sometimes he hate you guys he wants to
trade some some grain for some shoes
then he's got to actually you know farm
some green the Gulf on shoemaker it
gives diagrams that here you go let me
give you some new shoes buddy that
there's an exchange taking place there
right so he says the labor of the
individual it for his own needs is just
a bunch of satisfaction of the needs of
others as of his own and the
satisfaction of his own needs he attains
only through the labor of others again
there is nobody who is an entirely
self-made person you know think about
Robinson Caruso the person the person
that people like to point towards now
when you read Robinson Caruso as a book
if you want to use that as an example go
back to those first chapters and see the
inventory of stuff that he took from the
ship that he didn't make himself and
then used so that he could make stuff
for himself even though he's a guy on a
desert island he's not totally cut off
at least in terms of material
possessions any knowledge of how to use
them from society he's just locally
removed you might say from society but
he's benefiting from this Universal
exchange of labor this circulation of
labor that that's going on so he goes on
Hagel goes on and he says as the
individual in his individual work
already unconsciously let me get this
without realizing without
knowing it performs a universal work
that's an interesting idea the
individual isn't just swapping things
with some other individual what they do
has Universal not just implications but
scope actuality they perform a universal
work when I feed somebody I don't just
feed that person I perform a universal
work when I go out and plow a field I
don't just turn turf into arable land I
perform a universal work when I save
somebody's life in the ER when I teach
somebody I perform a universal work
without even realizing it which means I
better perform it well right in part
because otherwise it's going to have
greater reverberations throughout the
society so he says sony any performs a
universal work ask is conscious object
the whole becomes a zabal his own work
for which he sacrifices himself and
precise length of doing receives back
from in his own self as the individual
becomes conscious at least dimly of
performing a universal work there's an
exchange between them and society they
received back because he said he
receives in some his own self back from
the universal sometimes with an
augmentation and quite a while we must
remark and acknowledge with a dim
munition this is precisely where
somebody like a Marxist would say ah ah
surplus value aha expropriation you know
all these sorts of things in that that's
true there are a lot of people think
about peasants for example they're
performing an invaluable Universal work
because if there's no food no society
for very long right but when they get
back and turn is hey your peasant that's
nice now keep working money and that's
not they're not getting back
fair exchange quite often a lot of this
him we might think about you know the
internet and how we talk about the
sharing economy and people should work
for exposure and all that I mean think
about what you're deriving you watch
these videos I don't actually charge for
these videos because i have Patrian
backers who are graciously providing
when you who probably aren't aback or
are getting to watch right doesn't
actually cover all of the costs of
hiring a trained professional to do all
this work let's assume that it did most
of the internet most of the stuff that
you have available there is Ben and
produced by people who are probably not
getting a hell of a lot of recognition
for it or a lot of remuneration and
quite a few of them have gotten you
might say tricked coerced talked into
doing a lot of things for free or for
very cheap and but it's produced a
universal work right I mean if you go to
one of the greatest things about this
because the internet encyclopedia
philosophy or the stanford encyclopedia
of philosophy i don't think even the
editors are getting paid maybe they are
i don't know but certainly the writers
aren't the writers are writing so that
they can benefit the society and get
some exposure you know get to practice
their expertise performing a universal
work then they get back a certain kind
of recognition we could come up with all
sorts of other examples like this as
well in any case euros a says there is
nothing here which would not be
reciprocal that's where it's getting a
little bit idealists because of it
nothing which would not be reciprocal
well we often find things editor but
were this what we're aiming for this is
what we desire according to Hegel this
is what we're trying to move towards in
history so he says the nothing in
relation to which the independents the
individual would not in the dissolution
of its being herself and the negation of
itself give itself it's positive
significance of being for itself the
individual is for it
not just in a you know pure reflexive
relation but mediated through not only
another individual but society so he
goes on and he says this unity of being
herself or making oneself a thing and a
being for self this universal substance
here we get the second part of the thing
up here speaks a universal language in
the customs and laws the zipa and the
Gazette's because that's of the nation
out of the group notice at this point
Hagel is not just talking about customs
he's talking about something that's
actually formulated and in some way more
consolidated that's not necessarily
written down but something that is more
official gazette so you know something
that's been established it has been that
said it's the set you know Gazette's is
what has been set down so he says that's
a universal language this is a really
interesting point actually I when I read
this I wanted to dwell on this again to
the commentary so we think of language
sometimes is having its own laws or as
being a customary kind of thing and yes
that that's all true but we think of my
images circle syntax and vocabulary
connected with a certain semantics and
pragmatics all this the sources we use
language is nice to love medium to do
the things that we want to do what's
that communication etc it's on it right
and then we have a moral sphere over
here with customs you should do things
this way this is the way we do things
around here people say this they don't
say that and then we have lots to do
this or we're going to punish you this
is what you have to do right it fuse
together no language is without value
judgments built into it even languages
where people are trying to change that
you know we're going to change the
vocabulary
so that we liberate everybody from
vocabulary that's so impressive you just
create another new impressive vocabulary
this is why South Park is such a
successful TV show because they have
their finger of this sort of thing and
we can talk about other lampooning of
that sort of stuff as well you from eyes
all you like there's nobody's going to
be some value judgments built at so the
key is not yet not have value japon
judgments try to make sure that they're
the right value judgments it's how you
talk about that play in through the
language but itself is imbued with value
judgments Hagel in some very interesting
stuff to say here at this point he says
this existent unchangeable essence is
the expression of the very individuality
which seems opposed to it the laws
proclaim what what each individual does
and also what each individual is so in
receiving its own self back from the
universal it's not just you know getting
back its own labor or something like
that it's also getting back its again we
have our identity largely provided to us
by the social fabric with in which we
live within which recognition can take
place so he goes on and he says the
individual knows are not only is his
Universal objective thing hood
objectified right but equally knows
himself in them or knows that was
particularized in his own individuality
in a night of his fellow-citizens mid
burn people who live within literally
the same municipality the same community
so he says in the universal spirit each
has only the certainty of himself
finding in the actual world nothing but
himself he is as certain of the others
as he is of himself I perceive in all of
them the fact that they know themselves
to be only these independent beings just
as I mean this is I perceiving them the
free unity with others in such wise that
just as this unit exists through me so
it exists for the others too i regard
that and myself and myself is
again I've already said many times
there's a bit idealistic this is what
we're driving towards spirits works
spirits exists spirit develops through
this sort of interaction that Hagel is
sketching out here recognition occurs
through this is one of the essential
activities or you might say eventual
products and goals of spirit